what up space fam goals in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest crazy developments in the one
punch man story
things are getting especially crazy
right now and i've gotten plenty of
comments requesting that i do an update
on the story so this seemed like the
perfect time
for it if you do enjoy seeing one punch
man on this channel and want to keep the
videos coming the best thing you could
do
is channel the caped baldy within and
one punch that like button if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial hit the notification bell and
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one punch man videos
and while you wait for the next one
punch man video to come out feel free to
check out our one punch man playlist
which includes videos on blast
all s-class heroes all god and dragon
level threats and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all last
time the very attractive fubuki
stepped in and used telekinesis to save
genos from destruction
she was absolutely amazing and although
it's an ongoing joke that she calls
s-class heroes subordinates she truly
was acting like an amazing leader
when she stepped up to deal with the
situation defeat used up so much of her
power
that she passed out leaving bang and the
others amazed at her potential to become
a great leader
after all now we jump to this chapter
and we see tatsumaki in the air
we got dragon level threat homeless
emperor talking about symphonies and how
they use
every possible sound to bring forth
harmony a thing of ultimate beauty
similarly he views his own fighting as
an artistic performance
and announces the grand finale but it
was just a decoy
and not actually tatsumaki also let's
just once more appreciate the fact that
there is a one punch man villain called
black sperm in truth tatsumaki is not in
great shape
tornado of terror shows up and calls out
her sister's name
we all know how important fubuki is to
her and fubuki wakes up
shocked to see that tatsumaki is in much
worse shape
than even she is nevertheless tatsumaki
is very mad that fubuki is hurt
and her power explodes tatsumaki has
never looked scarier as
she asks her sister to point out who
heard her so
i love how tatsumaki can be so insanely
cute and so insanely terrifying
at the same time after fubuki lets her
sister know that she's here out of her
own free will
and the injuries are of her own doing
tatsumaki immediately and hilariously
calms down
letting fubuki know to hurry up and go
home tatsumaki goes on to finish off the
other fodder
as she calls them even though they're
dragon level threats
i appreciate her confidence even more so
because fubuki points out that she's on
the brink of death this time fubuki
wants to protect her sister saying i
quote
anymore and you'll die if you don't stop
you're bleep but before she can finish
the statement
tatsumaki struggling for breath sends
her flying back
saying not to underestimate her fubuki
wouldn't be able to help her in a
million years
that's tatsumaki's issue she's such a
tsundere
and she doesn't want to accept help from
anyone
she's okay with being the rescuer but
never the rescued
fubuki tries to stop her with a
telekinetic ring
and this is pretty funny because it's
like using genjutsu
against hitachi fubuki is begging at
this point saying that tatsumaki has no
strength left and she really will die
and i'm not surprised by this after all
it's not just that tatsumaki looks bad
she's taken insane damage over and over
again throughout these
chapters and now with fubuki being so
sure she's about to die
it really doesn't look good for our
favorite op tsundere there's some great
development here between the sisters
fubuki recalls how tatsumaki
stopped trusting others so she could
protect fubuki but that led to fubuki
being frightened and isolated
so she created her own faction and used
power to move past that scared point
however fubuki feels like since then
she's begun to understand strength and
her sister better she promises to gather
strong allies that even tatsumaki can
trust
and then she'll come for tatsumaki who
won't have to carry the whole burden on
her own anymore
and whether we've realized it or not
fubuki has been doing this with people
like saitama jenos and bang
even if tatsumaki doesn't trust others
yet we know saitama is even stronger
than her
and could protect her if it came down to
it interestingly enough
fubuki says she'll say tatsumaki but in
a different way
not in the conventional being strong way
and i really like that distinction
with tears in her eyes fubuki smiles and
says she'll save her sister
because she's a hero and tatsumaki's
expression to hearing this must be
in my top 3 adorable things i've ever
seen still though
tatsumaki turns the tables she frees
herself from fubuki's ring
and traps the three of them in rings she
compliments fubuki on getting stronger
but says she can't go on thinking anyone
will come and save her
and you might recall that that's what
blast told tatsumaki when he saved her
so long ago
and tatsumaki has lived by that
philosophy ever since
and she decides that she's gotta be a
good example to fubuki and marches
towards the enemy as her trapped sister
can only cry and watch
believing that tatsumaki is walking
towards her own death
and as she mentions even though blast
saved tatsumaki back then
he left a curse on her heart she would
rather die in battle than accept help
from others and that could very well be
her undoing
it's an interesting situation and idea
originally what blast said was good
advice
don't wait for someone else to save you
start working on saving yourself however
after a certain level
needing to do everything on your own can
be a weakness
and we see that here where it appears to
be leading tatsumaki to her end
the fact is humans are social animals
and we rely on each other whether we're
aware of that fact or not
just think of one piece all the
strongest pirates in the world have a
crew that they rely on
but back to one punch man jenos puts a
jacket over fubuki
always a nice moment to see and lets her
know that he's going to back up
tatsumaki it's a touching moment
he ensures them that he won't use his
full power
so he doesn't overheat and promises to
protect tatsumaki for the shippers you
can definitely argue there's some
chemistry between
genos and fubuki here in which case
lucky demon cyborg
jenos also recalls how saitama shows
respect to people who fight and risk
their lives regardless of their capacity
he recalls the great moomin rider in
fact someone who may not be the
strongest but
man is he inspirational and i agree with
saitama here
yeah we're not all as strong as saitama
but what matters is your character and
you can live by your own principles no
matter how talented or untalented you
are and at the end of the day that's
what counts i love to see bang
acknowledge fubuki as his leader as he
goes to do his part too
fubuki's face is so cute as she looks at
him wide-eyed
clearly touched by all their actions i
always find it funny and
great when genos as he does here insists
that he's nobody else's disciple except
caped baldi's
and he makes sure everyone knows it
especially bang
we drum two people commenting that
tatsumaki's powers
and the devastation they caused are
comparable to a nuclear weapon which is
crazy to think about if she expended
that much energy
already how much longer could she
possibly keep going
we catch up with my boy tank top master
and
pig god who are taking on dragon level
threat to gums
dragon level fury ugly shows up too
having seemingly overcome
sweet mask with his power and ugliness
it's unbelievable the dude actually rips
off sweet mask's arm
i did not expect that and he plans to
keep
ripping off body parts the heroes are in
a terrible position right now we could
really use saitama right about now
and having blast thrown in wouldn't be
bad either gums catches tank top master
between his teeth
and it seems like he's going to bite
right through him of course this can't
be possible not when he's wearing a tank
top of all things luckily before tank
top master is finished off
pig god saves him and tatsumaki shows up
to save sweet mask from being stomped
out too
pig god takes people into his mouth and
tank top master sends them flying off
away from the dangerous dragon level
threats he wants to pass on the message
that they will
win to moomin rider the legend of the
tank top
continues fury ugly gets uglier and
stronger and punches tatsumaki who
remember is knocking on death's door
already
and she's punched right into a rock here
tank top master
uses tank top tackle against an ugly
punch and i know
this will be hard to believe but even
with the tank top his arms get destroyed
it doesn't look like he can fight
anymore furthermore
tatsumaki has hit her head hard and
looks to be completely out of it
i gotta give credit to the drawing if
you're ugly when he goes in to hit
tank top master a second time it is
truly ugly
and unsettling ugly punches the master
and although it doesn't look good
tank top master ensures us despite all
this
ugly power the tank top is invincible
my god what a legend
ugly keeps going though and it's hard to
imagine tank top master surviving that
especially as a chapter ends with what
remains of him
going into gum's throat but even though
it looks really bad
we can hope that the power of the tank
top may bring about some sort of
miracle ugly approaches tatsumaki who
looks completely defenseless and
powerless
and that's the end of this insane
chapter it's straight up seems like tank
top master is dead and like tatsumaki is
pretty much as good as that
was fubuki right can this be blamed on
blast's curse
that's led tatsumaki to put herself in
harm's way time after time without
relying on anyone
let me know your thoughts and how you
like the chapter in the comments
hopefully we'll see saitama and blast
again soon
clearly the heroes need help asap and i
feel like blasts gotta give tatsumaki
some more advice to balance out his old
advice
we'll see what happens i do have my
hopes very high for the next chapter
whatever happens though we must remember
the tank top
is invincible long live the tank top
we can't put hashtag rip tank top in the
chat
because the tank top we must remember
never dies but that is it for this one
thanks again for watching
we got the usual hilarity combined with
intensity
and very serious and perhaps mortal
wounds
can't wait for the next chapter to come
out if you did enjoy this one punch
review
and want to keep them coming the best
thing you could do is channel the kate
baldy within
and one punch that like button if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit the bell and turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one punch man videos
and while you wait for the next one
punch man video to come out
feel free to check out my one punch man
playlist which includes videos on blast
all s-class heroes
all god and dragon level threats and
much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patrons of legend
the ones acknowledged by lord twego
himself alpha sigma
red-haired raven and av and our one-tier
patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata pate heffa al-jatal
dr cortman the toasted chi bang emperor
taku spy life tinel tungsten tarcus
baked buddhist and
yuno and our pro hero to your patrons
the one and only gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazatsuki
cricket xp returned day aura very gucci
alicia actor bonnie
parks xenokami and water joanne garcia
ted noted i sparky65
jessica lafond metal mama corey mcgowan
fat boy games deadly saints soul rise
slice and dice and pill you thank you
all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access
to our private patron only discord where
we talk about
anime life and of course thank memes so
check out patreon.com
anime uproar link in the description if
you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button that
you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer and whichever way
to support us
you will get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you